a new threat from russia to the u.s this
morning over what it calls the possible
seizure of russian assets in ukraine a
statement from the russian foreign
ministry did not specify what assets it
was referring to but did say american
actions could destroy moscow's bilateral
relations with washington at the same
time two more ships left ports on the
black sea today bringing the total
number of ships to depart ukraine under
a u.n broker deal to 16. on the
battlefield fighting is continuing to
rage in ukraine's southeast with
europe's biggest nuclear plant at the
center of recent attacks charlie dagetta
reports now on the surge in fighting
this video may be a handout from the
russian ministry of defense purportedly
firing on ukrainian military targets but
no one here needs evidence whether
russian forces have intensified attacks
in this region in the past few days
especially after the explosions that
rocked a russian air base in crimea
earlier this week the ukrainian
government has been reluctant to claim
responsibility or elaborate on exactly
what took place while acknowledging that
a number of warplanes have been
destroyed
outside the front-line city of mikalai
we spoke with commander roman cooley you
have seen a marked difference since the
attacking crime yeah yes yes the
difference is the increased shelling he
said and the russians seem to want to
show they have an advantage in
long-range artillery weapons
the stepped-up shelling coincides with a
surge in fighting in and around the zapa
region nuclear power plant president
vladimir zelinsky accused russian forces
of using it as a shield
russia has turned to open nuclear
blackmail he said what's happening now
around the zaparisian nuclear power
plant is one of the biggest crimes of
the terrorist states
the nuclear watchdog iaea has called for
an immediate end to military activity
yet amid the darkness there has been
some light
after a week where a dozen or so grain
ships have left port in ukraine there
are expectations that the first u.n
cargo ship might soon be leaving for the
horn of africa where it's needed most a
lifeline sent away from a country that
could use one itself for cbs saturday
morning charlie dagena near mikalive
ukraine